so hateful Hillary Clinton is back at it
and doing what she does best attacking
Trump supporters this time she says they
are in a cult so many of those
extremists those Mega extremists um take
their marching orders from Donald Trump
who has no credibility left by any
measure he's only in it for himself he's
now defending himself in civil actions
and criminal actions and when do they
break with him you know because at some
point you know maybe there needs to be a
formal deprogramming of the cult members
but something needs to happen the base
of the Republican party for whatever
combination of reasons and it is
emotional and
psychological um sees in him someone who
speaks for them maybe they don't like
migrants maybe they don't like gay
people or black people or the woman who
got the promotion at work they didn't
get whatever the reason so it is like a
cult and somebody has to break the uh
you know break that
momentum haha so Hillary thinks millions
of trump voters need to be
deprogrammed it's a pathetic new low for
the twice failed presidential candidate
but it's not a total shock it seems like
Hillary has been thumbing through the
dictionary and finding new ways to
demonize Republicans who can forget the
basket of
deplorables you can put
half of Trump's supporters into what I
call the basket of deplorables I
remember as a as a young student you
know trying to figure out how did people
get
basically um drawn in by Hitler you saw
the rally in Ohio the other night Trump
is there ranting and raving for uh more
than an hour and you have these
rows of young men with their arms raised
I thought what is going on Hillary
Hillary must be spooked perhaps it's
because a majority of Americans trust
Donald Trump and the Republicans to do a
better job on the key issues that matter
to
voters there's been one poll after
another poll after another poll this
week that has shown that the Republicans
are just absolutely uh bashing Democrats
when it comes to issues look at this
Republicans over Democrats on issues
like inflation the economy immigration
these are 25 nearly 30 point margins
creating jobs it's unbelievable huge
huge
numbers all right Jessica you would hear
words like deplatforming deprogramming
cult all haters uh in countries like the
Soviet Union China North Korea isn't
that in itself a threat to
democracy Hillary Clinton giving an
interview no uh saying what she said in
the interview no it it's not a threat to
democracy does it land in a bunch of GOP
ads heading into an election sure that's
what happened with the basket of
deplorables comment but I really need
everyone to spare me the foe outrage and
the Pearl clutching about this little
collection of things that Donald Trump
and high-ranking Republicans call
liberals on a daily basis Anarchist
anti-American deranged Communists
corrupt compromised groomers and
perverts Thugs and traitor
now she was explicit that she was
talking about a subsection of the
Republican Party the same way that Joe
Biden is when he talks about this Maga
extremism but you tell me if the
leader of the democratic party so that
that would be Joe Biden was facing four
indictments with 91 felony counts he had
been found liable of sexually assaulting
a woman and defaming her that's eege
Carol guilty of fraud sharing the
nation's secrets not only in the
maralago indictment but there was a
report yesterday from ABC news that he
had shared information about our nuclear
submarine capacities with an Australian
billionaire who's a member at maralago
who had then gone on and shared that
with dozens of other people end up
making a purchase I think of three subs
and included specifics up to how many
nuclear warheads they carry and how
close they can get to Russian Subs
without being detected and then I told
you so all of that is happening and he's
shooting up in the polls and when you
see those interviews of trump supporters
out side of the rallies they're like
none of this is true it's the big lie he
won the election Etc and you wouldn't
say to me you guys are in a cult it's
actually tame what Hillary Clinton was
saying Jesse you know um no one on the
Republican Party side has called for the
silencing of newspapers and social media
conversation excuse me I'm asking Jesse
question okay they no one on the
Republican side has said do not let
anyone talk about hun 's laptop make
sure that the conservatives get
suppressed on social media I mean this
is consistent with the whole idea of
silencing Americans if they don't agree
with the left I want to be deprogrammed
by Hillary I want to be told that
Federman is a smart dresser and Joe
Biden's smart and the laptop's real I
want to wake up in the morning and be
forced to watch Morning Joe tell me what
a woman is and then I want to read the
New York Times and watch Paul Krugman
tell me now is the time to refinance my
at 8% these are the things that we all
need to do we need to bring our masks
back probably get boosted and buy
tickets to Hamilton but if we go buy
tickets to Hamilton we go in in our
Teslas and we get car jacked I'm going
to be reprogrammed to not tell the
police what the perpetrator looked like
because I don't need to be revictimized
people but I do have to get home to read
Jesse Jr a bedtime story he needs to
read a book about gay sex before bed
these are the kind of things that that
Hillary will reprogram the entire
country to do I want to be told that my
wife should be at CrossFit and I need to
be home supporting her and making her
dinner these are the types of things we
need to do everything now is on the
table okay and if we don't know these
things and we don't understand that
Russia interfered in the election and
that the lab leak is a conspiracy theory
then we're just not good Americans she
has to do this Jessica because she has
lost her ability to persuade us she
cannot through deed or
action make people understand that she
relates to them she says I don't know
why people relate to Trump and thinks he
represents us well that's why because
Hillary has abandoned this country she
cannot connect with the voters and this
is what people do in North Korea she got
millions more votes than he this is what
people do in North Korea when their
entire country country is devastated by
dumb policies they try to brainwash The
Peasants into believing everything is
great she knows it's over and that's all
they have left Greg Joe Scarboro thinks
it's unbelievable that the Republicans
are so far ahead in terms of the economy
crime immigration is he living in an
alternate universe no it could be he
just might be
stupid I mean there's usually that that
could always be the option if you ever
watch Morning Joe you can tell uh a
couple of things number one you got to
Define what a cult is okay uh a cult
isn't defined by its supporters it's def
it's defined by destroying those who
don't support you so Scientology is not
a cult because because it has followers
it is a cult because it goes after
people who leave or people that are
against it that is the the party of the
Democrats who created cancel culture
wasn't the Republicans it was the
Democrats what you're seeing right now
it's a bigger issue you're seeing cancel
culture on a wider larger scale you
wonder why people are worried about 2024
because there are a group of Elites that
are already placing Targets on people's
backs from the top Elon Musk and Trump
to the bottom the January 6th
trespassers and if you call it out if
you dare to call it out a Target will be
placed on you if you talk about issues
that matter that the Democrats have
abandoned whether it's immigration or
crime or education you will need
deprogramming you will go to the Camp
again this is cancel culture it is no
longer a bug in the system it is the
system you have the FBI now targeting
Maga uh Republicans as um terrorists
that's part of this equation so how
should the rest of us react how should
half the country react should we just
laugh it off I mean you said Trump says
all these bad things or actually you
didn't say that you said this is what
people say about liberals and
Democrats fine that's name calling Trump
targeted people in power he didn't go
after voters right she goes after voters
she goes after Americans he went after
the media and he went after politicians
and he went after the Democratic party
he never went after quote the the the
small D Democrat so it validates
everything that Trump has said and
others they are coming for you they're
just no longer hiding it they want us to
be scared they want us to stay home they
want you to think twice before you say
anything
or or like a post by Trump on Truth
social uh but what are we supposed to do
because if we say something about it
then we get targeted right that's what's
happening Kennedy with Biden losing
steam with Biden let me let me just go
with Biden losing steam in multiple
polls now is it the best play for the
Democrats to just smear Republicans or
do they is it smart for them to just
change policies as it sounds like Joe
Biden is trying to she's doing by going
so hard after Trump and his supporters
to Greg's point is pointing out what a
weak feeble and incompetent president
that we have if you know and and Jessica
believes what she's saying and and you
know you list some facts about the
former president you know he's under
indictment he's been charged he's been
found liable uh he's in a lot of trouble
given all of that on all of the critical
issues facing voters not just
Republicans Democrats Independence he's
still ahead in double digits where it is
most important to hurting voters and
that's inflation and the economy
according to these new polls he's 2530
points ahead of Joe Biden a cult leader
who who will see the inside of a
courtroom in a number of venues who is
so troubled and corrupt and compromised
that he's 25 points ahead from a sitting
president who according to Hillary
Clinton Clinton is a man of
accomplishment but she's talking about a
formal deprogramming that means at the
hands of the government and that is what
they do in North Korea that is what
happened to the South Vietnamese that is
what happened to people in Soviet Russia
who were disappeared by the tens of
millions and that's why civil
Libertarians fight to the death for
things like free speech because we have
to be able to talk about things we have
to be able to call people names we have
to be able to like things without fear
of Retribution or reprogramming and she
has shown her hand that is what she
wants to do because she has lost the war
she has lost the ideas and now she's
going after a person who is so
compromised he's beating the living
daylight out of someone who is
supposedly accomplished he's
accomplished at turning his own party
and good Americans away from him so in
that same pole by the way Biden is ahead
of Trump by two points but I want to say
something about what yeah look at it's
51 to 49% depends on the poll but no
that poll the poll you just showed but
there's an important point when you say
Trump doesn't go after the small D
people disen trying to disenfranchise
voters and make their votes not count
which is what he did in Arizona
Pennsylvania Georgia Etc with this big
lie about how he won the election that's
your
interpretation that's editorializing
what you inter a good opinion but it's
not real by the way I love how Hillary
said that you know what it could be they
don't like gay people this is from some
who uh did not was not for gay marriage
but Trump was yeah and a woman who had a
war room against other women so let's
not get started with Hillary hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else